so let's talk about antifa so so you
covered antifa on the ground we've been
told by the media that antifa
are alternatively world war ii era
allied troops storming the beaches of
normandy uh we've been told by joe biden
that they are not in fact
a group that they are in fact just sort
of a philosophy you know sort of like
sort of like cubism or something like an
artistic movement well what exactly is
antifa since you've covered them on the
ground
it's a uh i mean it's not necessarily
wrong to say that they're a movement or
an idea but it's the individual
cells that we're talking about i think
what you're talking about
and what they do is the mainstream media
uses a semantic argument to try and act
like they don't exist so
to put it simply antifa is the symbols
they use the ideology
typically fi you'll find many of these
people are authoritarian communists
and i'm not trying to exaggerate or do
some stupid oh they're all communists
not like
they're literally they believe in
authoritarian communism but uh
it's it's rooted in you know world war
pre-world war ii germany
weimar germany where you had the
communist party had their anti-fascist
day action
and it was challenging the fascists they
use the same symbols
they create small individual groups with
they say no leaders they have leaders
they do
and then they coordinate for various
actions they call them nationwide
so ultimately what you have are
political zealots
who believe in the use of violence for
political gain and terror
for political gain what they'll do is
they'll tell you
and they'll have allies in media tell
you there's no such thing as antifa it's
not a group
well that's a semantic manipulation
they're playing a game here
if i say antifa came out in portland and
attack people
i'm talking about rose city antifa it's
a legitimate group
they have membership they have
membership drives they put out
you know flyers on the or they put out a
website saying here's how you join our
group
they have their own merchandise that
says rose city antifa on it
so it would be like you know the media
is trying to use
a word play to trick you into believing
that these various groups don't exist
because if i said you know i went to
portland and antifa came out
then i went to boston and antifa came
out they say ah see that proves it
because there's no connection between
those two groups but it's
the general ideas they they they hold
that same ideology
wearing all black these similar tactics
they use the same symbols
and they typically agree with each other
on their cause
and their you know their means to the
end so you actually have
a loose knit group of various cells that
coordinate with each other using
violence against their political
opponents ah
for the most part instigating it
outright to to
to win and it works for them you know
the example i often give to people
why is it that social media is so
willing to censor
right-wing individuals but is literally
organizing
violent riots online even probably right
now they've been doing it
you know all year and for the past
several years and it's simple
antifa in say san francisco in the bay
area
they'll show up to the to the
headquarters of these big tech companies
and they'll trash the place
so these companies say well well you
know leave them alone but
there's not going to be a conservative
group marching to twitter hq with
pitchforks and torches
so long as big companies keep giving
antifa what they
want or showing them their tactics work
they'll keep doing what they do
as for the loosened nature of what they
do it's all on purpose
the reason why they don't have an
official nationwide organization is very
it's it's actually really easy to
understand when you look at the proud
boys
obviously the proud boys in antifa are
not the same things but there are
similarities in that you have these
these groups that fight on this on the
ground
the proud boys have a chairman enrique
tario well they've banned him from
dozens of banks they've banned them from
all the different platforms you give
someone a leader
they use that to actually try and
discredit the rest of your group
antifa knows this i've actually talked
to people going back to occupy wall
street who have straight up said
no leaders as soon as you put someone up
they'll smear they'll character
assassinate
so it is on purpose they say they don't
have leaders
however law enforcement knows who the
individual cell leaders are i would
imagine
and i think some of them got doxed
recently so it's really it's it's not
you know their tactics aren't perfect
but i will say the left is much much
better at street level organizing than
the right
and so you end up with a media narrative
that can't understand what antifa is or
outright defends them on purpose
i think there's there's two things
you've got the activist media
that hates donald trump and they're
saying what
you know oh antifa is no big deal but
they're saying it because
they want to protect antifa you then
have these local reporters these people
who are probably
you know they have good intentions
they're trying to be objective and fair
but they can't grasp the concept of
antifa as a group
because antifa has specifically
obfuscated what they really are
so you can't report on what they are
then you get someone like say andy no
or elijah schaefer someone like at one
point what i was doing
and we can actually accurately break it
down a report on the ground they get
really angry about that
and we all saw what happened to andy
know you know when he was out there in
portland they physically beat him they
left him bleeding and covered in you
know milkshake and stuff like that
those are the people they're really
worried about but long story short
they're they're radical far left they
typically are authoritarian communists
but not all of them some of them might
just be
they might be like left anarchist i know
there's a big debate over whether or not
anarchists can actually be left or right
but
they view themselves that way they'll
view themselves as socialists but the
big the big issue i see with antifa
is that you might find someone who will
try and lie and justify no no we don't
believe in violence where it's
self-defense but these are the
narratives they like to use
to get away with what they do and so
long as you have these mainstream
resistance type democrats who hate trump
they won't call these groups out
and that's been something i've
experienced going back to occupy wall
street
where the peaceful legitimate protesters
are told by these groups to respect
their quote
diversity of tactics it's this it's the
stupidest idea i've ever heard
the idea that you're going to engage in
some kind of strategy against a big
system but
diversify what that strategy is makes no
sense you want to have a cohesive plan
as to how you're going to make change
happen the the reality is these groups
say respect our diversity of tactics
because
that's code for getting violent and
hurting people and then you get these
good-natured protesters who just want to
you know wave their little signs and
banners and be heard
now standing back as antifa messes with
people knocks them down starts fires
so i will say i think antifa for the
most part is a colloquial term we use to
describe
the far left extremists who use what's
called the black bloc tactic
where you know they wear hoodies they
wear masks i don't know what we'll call
them in the future we just called them
the black block anarchists you know 10
years ago now they're antifa
they're still here they're still rioting
apparently the media calling it for joe
biden did nothing to change their minds
and in fact i think
it's only it's only likely to escalate
as if if we do enter a joe biden
administration because
certainly joe biden won't be strong
enough to deal with these groups that
are pressuring him and attacking him and
getting violent
and we already saw this i believe
recently they attacked a dnc
headquarters saying f joe biden
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional
leftist tear gleaming in the sunshine
don't ask me why that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity hit the like button